Madrid marcha en contra de la violencia
dirigida hacia las mujeres una violencia
que se puede manifestar de muchas
maneras
violencia en el ámbito de la pareja
agresiones sexuales vientres de alquiler
prostitución y mercantilización del
cuerpo de las mujeres y estamos
atravesando una revolución feminista de
este Irán hasta el resto del mundo y que
no va a tener otra otro final que la
victoria porque llevamos ya 43 años
siendo Víctimas de violencia continua
diaria institucional por primera vez en
la historia de España este día se
celebra con una legislación que protege
a las mujeres específicamente contra la
violencia sexual la conocida como ley
del solo sí es Sí en vigor desde octubre
tipifica como agresión sexual todo acto
que no cuente con el consentimiento
expreso voluntario y libre de la mujer
sin embargo la unión de el de abuso y el
de agresión ha hecho que se revisen las
penas mínimas lo que ha derivado en la
rebaja de condenas de algunos agresores
a la propuesta era buena y siempre está
bien intentar movilizar y hacer nuevas
propuestas que ayuden con estos
problemas pero una ley que lo que hace
es minimizar las cuentas hace que los
violadores vuelvan a las calles Yo es
que ya no le doy desde el punto de vista
legal pero es que las chicas que se
quedaron tranquilas porque saben que sus
violadores están entre rejas ahora
tienen que volver a estar fuera es que
me pongo en su lugar y me parece una
polémica que no debería desviar la
atención sobre el escalofriante hecho de
que en lo que va de año en España 38
mujeres han sido asesinadas por sus
parejas o exparejas y otras 19 por
hombres a los que conocían pero con
Quienes no mantenían una relación
sentimental más de una vida cada semana
que deja de existir solo por el hecho de
haber nacido mujer